Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! This is going
to be a big Legends of Tomorrow update they
were doing upfronts for international TV buyers
and the actors revealed more details about
the show it was actually the CTV upfronts and
if you're wondering about where in the world
it will be available
all the places that the flash and Arrow are
available it's been selling really well internationally
so firstly big detail season one is going
to be 15 episodes long and there probably
will be a season to the CW hasn't ordered
a second season yet you usually they way towards
the first couple of episodes to see how it
shows doing that is being planned out just
like Arrow the flash are so it'll keep going
as long as they wanted to keep going it's
going to start in January whenever Arrow in
flash comeback met the official date is and
confirmed that air on the flash comeback about
the third week in January so it's pry one
is going to start and a lot of you are asking
why is it only 15 episodes that's a totally
where number will I think there's a lot of
evidence in the way they pitch the series
Mark Guggenheim said that if the flash is
supposed to feel like a one-hour movie each
week legends is supposed to feel like a one-hour
summer blockbuster every week and it's really
hard to up the level of spectacle and special-effects
every week if you have to spread your budget
across 23 episodes with a probably done is
the same thing that Agent Carter did you reduce
the number of episodes the you produce but
you get the same budget you would for a full
series of full series order can be anything
from like 18 to 24 episodes so the CW prided
is like okay will give you the money for 23
episodes just like we would for any other
series like the flasher Arrow you know similar
budget you produce your episodes you get to
spend way more money on each episode just
to make it that much crazy looking that that
much more bigger badass it just that whenever
Agent Carter aired they budget without you
around like 13 episodes like you would a limited
series the only produced eight so they got to spent
almost twice as much money for each episode
that doesn't mean that legends is always going
to be 15 episodes long but ill always prior
to be a like a slightly reduced runs they
can spend a little bit more money on each
episode in the really important thing to remember
is that 15 number because Arrow in the flash
last year only aired 14 episodes in the back
half. So you see where I'm going here you know there will be a
lot of crossovers between all three shows
what they might do is the same thing they
did with the Aero the flash finale this year
were the characters crossover and then like
in the finale of the second show everything
is resolved we might have some issues like
in the last episode of Arrow that the people
help out with from the other shows in the
story carries over into the flash finale
the week after that and then the week after
that in and like the third week in Legends of
Tomorrow everything gets resolved so you have
a lot of overlapping stories and there's a
reason why each showed doesn't have their
finale in the same week the year which we
have no idea what day it's going to air on
you know it'll pry your on a different save
from air on the flash just so they can maximize
crossover potential of the is either going
to be Monday earth can be like Thursday it
all just comes down to like what they want
to show to compete against the problem with
Mondays are is that the CW is a big fan of
that 8 o'clock time slot early that's where
Supergirl is going to be airing on CBS so
if ledges is tomorrow words air on Mondays
at 8 PM it will be competing with Supergirl
and I don't think that they want to do that
if you haven't seen any my previous videos
it just the same people that make Arrow the
flash and Legends of Tomorrow also makes Supergirl
so like they they want them all to do well
Thursday and Friday are just like the logical
places to stick that just because Sunday night
is so competitive with like walking dead in
way more popular shows Fridays, like a graveyard
of TV that's like where you send a TV show
when you wanted to die so I just I feel like
Thursday is the best option after that that
way if something happened on the flash on
Tuesday could carry over to Arrow the next
day and the data that they could solve the
problem so if they wanted to they could tell
like an entire self-contained three-part story
in a single week that feels like a really
bad ass movie which is what they're kinda
trying to create the trying to create like
a movie type universe on TV another a lot
of questions about like a big crossovers because
we had flash versus Arrow and we have brave
and the bold they're going to keep doing that
with Aaron the flash but now that we have
legends there probably going to do like one
big full Aero type crossover and then a couple
more minor ones me that you'll have an episode
where everybody's in like that the pilot probably
everybody's going to be in that first episode
after that though whenever characters crossover
and pride in their own so like you have a
flash episode of legends of tomorrow and you
have like and Arrow episode legends is tomorrow
for the most part though Barry and all of
her will stay on their own shows just because
legends is going to revolve around its main
actors which give like a white canary the
Adam firestorm Victor Garber the guy that
plays Martin Stein actually said a little
bit about what's going on with firestorm so
he kind confirmed that firestorm would appear
in the first episode of the flash season to
just is a follow-up to like that big you know
universe altering time vortex and he and Ronnie
Raymond would appear in the first episode
of ledges is tomorrow and that even pry go
their separate ways didn't say anything about
Ronnie Raymond died but I know everyone's
wondering why Robbie and Mel isn't on the
spinoff show in is probably just because is
film careers taking off and is a budget conflicts
seriously since the tomorrow people and it
he's been shooting a ton of movies so he pry
just wasn't able to sign up for the full series
so they had to write a story around that to
explain why he wasn't around market and I
did say that they wouldn't put like one half
of firestorm on legends it tomorrow without
allowing him to do firestorm things saving
money Ronnie leaves Martin Stein will still
be doing firestorm stuff meaning that will
probably have to go to Jason Rush like a said
that doesn't confirmed that Ronnie is going to
die or anything that in the comics issues
that Jason Rush only became firestorm when
Ronnie died that was during the identity crisis
storyline knows you know long time ago it
seems like for now like the flare of personnel
legends air on the flash are sticking with
the paradigm that firestorm acquires two people
to operate one person to be the body and one
mind to drive the body DC change that a long
time ago in the comics the latest they made
it so that Jason Rush and Ronnie Raymond can
both be firestorm on their own. They don't
need Martin Stein the even did like the Transformers
thing where like when Ronnie and Jason both
become firestorm they can combine to form
like a supergiant mega firestorm which is kind of funny they are totally not to do that on
the TV show this is way too ridiculous the
ministry character they could be Jason Rush
is the Jade Jackson character that could be
like a like a placeholder name just like you
do with Ted Kord earlier this year he and that
being Ray Palmer instead the reasoning behind
turning Ted Kord into Ray Palmer on Arrow with
was a little bit different that was like
a DC executive decision they were like
"we have other plans for Ted Kord you can't
use blue beetle".  kind of a bummer because I
feel the way Brandon Routh's character worked
was designed for Ted Kord. it's just a that storyline
you like the Felicity Ray storyline was was
meant to be a little bit lighter little bit
more awkward that is Ted Kord through and
through, Ray Palmer has a little bit of a harder
edge. Brandon Routh is an a great job of making
that character his own but I feel like it's
going to take most of Legends of Tomorrow to
develop him. But just going back to firestorm,  I feel like the only reason they
have for not announcing who this mystery Jay
Jackson character is going to be like the comic
book character he's playing, is that it it's
a big plot spoiler for firestorm like the
JJ in Jay Jackson is supposed to be a reference
to the RR of Ronnie Raymond that's just
a theory though and remember even if it is
Jason Rush and he becomes part of firestorm
it doesn't mean that they have to kill off
Ronnie Raymond Rob email is is like too big
of an actor for them to throw away so the
private find a way for him to come back in
the future here's my big question for you
guys though do you feel like Jay Jackson
is Jay Jackson character is really supposed
to be Jason Rush and Hill become part of firestorm
and a lot of you are also asking about Arthur
Darvill's Rip Hunter character I am there to
do a separate bonus video for him but there
are a couple big storylines the can read to
prepare this one called time Masters vanishing
point it came after final crisis when
darkseid's omega deam sent batman back
in time, Rip Hunter assembled a team to time
travel and find him. There's also this other
series just called time Masters is from the
early 90s the really cool thing about Rip
Hunter is that he is booster gold's son nicest
douchebag time traveler in the DC universe
a while ago in the comics they actually explain
why booster gold has to be such a douchebag
is really just an act so that people don't
know what his true purpose is booster is like
the secret origin of the time Masters obviously
time Masters is rip Hunter but booster gold
gives birth to rip Hunter who gives birth
to the time Masters so booster gold himself
very important in the history of the universe
as to the big villain Vandal Savage, mid-December
video for 7 wrote a story for him to read
is DC 1 million that's like a three-part story
so this is pretty small there's DC universe
presents for him to Vandal Savage that's all
about his daughter is I get a very Hannibal
Lecter Silence of the Lambs type story and then
there's demon knights which is a story set
during medieval times the DC universe you
actually know it demon nights that's the best
Vandal Savage story, so just start there I will
talk more about some of the stories in my
Vandal Savage video but my next video will
provide be that rip Hunter video so be sure
to subscribe to get that I'll try and post that next
week. I feel like talking about legends of tomorrow
is a good warm-up for Doctor Who, which is
actually going to start later this summer I
most of you guys, if you've never watched
Doctor Who before, let me know just so I can adjust my
videos accordingly. I'm not really going to do stuff
for that till July or August, so don't worry
about that yet but in case you guys didn't
see in my guardians to video that I did yesterday
I'm doing a new weekly Marvel and DC giveaway
that's two different giveaways every week
and it'll start whenever a post by Marvel
and DC videos next week in whichever first
so just be sure to check out any
Marvel or DC videos that post next week for
details I am working on Arrow season four video
that should post later tonight but while you
wait for that can click here to learn all
about Mirror Master coming this season to the
flash and can click here to learn about some
of my favorite Batman stories from decade to decade
Arkham Knight is right around the corner. thank
you so much for watching, everybody let's
high five and I'll see you tonight!